A newly released
review
by the US State Department claims
that the Biden administration
bungled several
aspects of the American withdrawal
from Afghanistan in August.
2021 CNN
national security correspondent
Kyla Abbott is live
for us from the State Department.
And highly
unlike the White House
report released yesterday,
this separate
State Department
review identifies several clear missteps
from the Biden administration
that contributed to the chaotic
and deadly withdrawal. Tell us more.
Yeah, that's right.
So according to our sources,
Jake this State Department
after action
report
has far more findings and recommendations
in it
than the document
that was put out yesterday
from the White House.
And according
to our sources
who have either seen this report
or have been described the report,
they say that there are 34
recommendations in total
and they're very specific.
They talk about doing things
such as putting a single official
in charge
when there are the complex
crisis situations
like this
or standing up a red team
to challenge assumptions
that are being made.
These are things
that the Biden administration did not do
during the Afghanistan withdrawal
and recommendations
for how it could have gone better now.
In contrast, that White House document
that was put out yesterday
does cite some lessons
learned, such
as prioritizing earlier evacuations.
But what it really does
is dwells on the decisions
that were made
during the Trump administration
and says that those decisions
that were made, such as striking a deal
with the Taliban
to get out the US
completely from the country,
drawing down U.S.
troops in the country,
severely constrained
what President Biden was able to do.
And so there is a disconnect
between these two reports.
The NSC is saying
that they are simply separate reports
that the one from the White House
was drawing on certain parts
of the State Department report,
but it wasn't mirroring it.
What are you hearing from
members of Congress
and diplomats
about the White House report?
Yeah, so members of Congress,
particularly Republicans,
are being very critical of what
the White House put out yesterday.
Congressman McCaul,
who is leading
the investigation into the Biden
administration withdrawal
from Afghanistan,
saying, quote,
that it was a brazen whitewashing
of their failure in Afghanistan,
calling it disgraceful
unjust and flat-Out insulting.
And then we talk to diplomats
in this building
who frankly are more interested in seeing
what the State Department's
report findings actually are,
because those haven't been made
public yet, Jake.
And our understanding is that even though
parts of this report
were largely classified,
the findings themselves were not.
But the State Department
still has yet to release those widely
except for sending it to Congress
yesterday Jake.
All right.
Candidate Kylie
Atwood at the State Department,
thanks so much.
Let's bring in former
Republican Congressman
Peter Meyer of Michigan.
He's a former sergeant
in the Army Reserves.
He served in Iraq.
He also spent some time in Afghanistan
as a civilian aid worker.
And as we covered in August 20, 21,
he secretly flew to Kabul
during the frenzied U.S.
evacuation back then
with Congressman Seth Moulton.
Congressman, good to see you.
So you call the White House
report on withdrawal.
You call it shameful.
You call it a craven whitewash of events.
Tell us why
Oh, it's a political document,
plain and simple.
This was the
Biden administration's attempt
to basically shift
blame back onto the Trump
administration for what happened
under the Biden administration's watch.
In response to the hearings
that are taking place on Capitol Hill,
with the now Republican majority
finally scrutinizing
the withdrawal operation,
I mean, that was
I served in 117th Congress
while this was occurring,
and the Democratic majority refused
to probe
deeply,
refused to ask the tough questions
of the State Department
of the Biden
administration in terms
of how this withdrawal
went so catastrophically wrong.
And finally,
there are those questions being asked.
And the White House felt
they needed to respond.
And they put this report out as a
political document
and nothing more
without letting the Biden administration
off the hook in any way.
Do you agree
that the Trump administration,
you know, in negotiating
with the Taliban, did
constrain the Biden administration
to a degree in terms of
the withdrawal being mandated
Well, if you remember, under
the Doha agreement
that the Trump administration
signed with the Taliban,
it initially had a May
20, 21 withdrawal date.
The Biden administration coming in,
and it should be remembered
that President Biden,
as a campaign pledge
similar to President Trump,
vowed to get our troops
out of Afghanistan. Right.
So he may have been constrained
by the troop numbers.
There were 2500 American
service members in country
by the time
the Biden administration took office,
but he changed the deadline from May 1st
to September the 11th
and then realized the political optics of
that were bad.
So moved it back to August 31st.
But frankly, again, I'm not going to say
that the Trump administration
set the Biden administration
up for success,
but the Biden administration
executed the withdrawal
and happened on their watch
And the fact that nobody
in this administration
takes responsibility for it,
there has been
no one who has resigned or suffered
any negative consequences
from a career standpoint because of this.
It's shameful.
That hasn't been the case
in other NATO countries,
and it just shows
how desperately
this administration
wants to leave Afghanistan
in the rearview mirror.
National security spokesman Admiral Kirby
took issue
with the
description of the withdrawal as chaotic.
But as it was happening,
he didn't have an issue with it.
With that description,
I want you to listen to him in 20, 21
follow Ed by what
he told reporters yesterday
The crowd size is smaller
now than it was in those first few days.
And and so we're not experiencing
to the degree we did last Monday
the physical crush and chaos
for all this talk of chaos.
I just didn't see it. Not from my perch.
So, I mean, he did acknowledge
seeing the chaos that we all saw,
you know, babies being lifted into the
airport grounds.
The people running
clinging to the plane, etc., etc..
The 13 service members
killed by the suicide bomber
in August 2021.
And then yesterday
he said
he didn't see chaos from his perspective.
What was your reaction to that?
Astonishment
at just a loss of words.
I mean, this was a very well-documented,
horrific chaotic moment.
Now, when it came to what
our men and women on
the ground were doing,
they were incredibly,
incredibly heroic
and dedicated to the mission
that they were forced into.
But they tried to make order
out of the chaos that was there,
but denying that there was chaos.
I mean, it's equivalent to telling us
to not believe are lying eyes.
I mean,
and I'm grateful that journalists,
not only because of the footage
that was coming out,
but also
because many journalists
had either worked in Afghanistan
or had friends and colleagues
who were still there, fixers,
you know,
folks on the ground, local journalists,
you know, they know the truth.
The American public have seen the truth.
But now this is an attempt
to basically revise history
and pretend it was anything
other than what it was. And I
I'm just at a loss for words.
Yeah.
Former Republican Congressman
Peter Meyer of Michigan,
thank you so much.
Always good to see you, sir.